à Moscou se trouve notre invité Igor de
la Noé bonjour et merci de répondre à
FRANCE 24 vous êtes le directeur adjoint
de l'Observatoire franco-rus du lacoling
nous le disait à l'instant la stupeur et
général
quel est l'état d'esprit des Russes
aujourd'hui après ces attaques au drone
sur la capitale vous ressentez
l'inquiétude
bonjour alors écoutez à vrai dire pas
vraiment en tout cas depuis le début de
journée enfin il est ici presque mieux
d'après-midi évidemment tout le monde en
parle c'est dans les discussions mais je
ressens pas de fébrilité d'inquiétude
dans les transports en commun que
j'emprunte quotidiennement ce matin les
gens étaient en train de dire leur
journaux regarder leur téléphone j'avais
pas le sentiment de voir face à moi des
mines paniqués ou autre
à vrai dire moi je l'ai appris la part
de proche qui m'ont contacté depuis la
France pour me demander comment comment
ça allait il y a eu des drones qui sont
tombés j'avais pas eu même eu le temps
de prendre connaissance en réalité de
ces de ces attaques donc moi j'aurais
tendance à dire que ça fait partie de la
nouvelle réalité mais que cette nouvelle
réalité quelque peu dissonante parce que
d'un côté dans le centre-ville par
exemple où je me trouve présentement les
terrasses sont bondées les gens vont
dans la rue en plus on attend magnifique
aujourd'hui enfin il y a vraiment une
ambiance estivale ou festival on n'a pas
le sentiment que les gens sont très
allés aux abris mais de l'autre côté
dans les quartiers qui sont de ceinture
la capitale russe qui est en 2500 km².
et dans les quartiers résidentiels qui
ont été touchés certainement que les
gens sont inquiets et sont beaucoup plus
je dirais au contact de cette nouvelle
réalité et pourtant c'est l'effet
psychologique qui est recherché par ces
attaques on ne sait toujours pas qui on
est l'auteur
à mon avis il y a pas vraiment de
mystère en revanche les psychologique
oui alors c'est plusieurs effets
recherchés bon déjà on sait pas
exactement combien de drones ont volés
sa défense dit 8 ce matin sur les
réseaux sociaux qui foisonnent de vidéos
comme c'était indiqué par votre confrère
juste avant on entendait en réalité
d'autres évaluations il y a différents
types de drones qui auraient pu être
utilisés bon on en saura peut-être plus
dans les jours qui viennent mais le fait
est que ces drones se dirigeaient
évidence vers la capitale vers le centre
je vois pas trop ce qui ciblait a priori
comme quel était leur cible exacte une
bonne partie d'entre probablement a été
séché sur le sur le trajet parce que je
rappelle qu'il y a plusieurs centaines
de kilomètres à parcourir pour arriver à
Moscou depuis la frontière ukrainienne
en réalité ça fait des mois que dans les
forêts des régions de Kaluga ou des
régions qui sont plus proches de
l'Ukraine on trouve des épaves de drones
parfois qui sont abîmés tout simplement
parce qu'il les font voler très bas pour
éviter les radars et parfois ils
accrochent les arbres et donc terminent
dans les forêts sans avoir atteint leur
cible donc oui un effet psychologique
parce que comme c'est indiqué les dégâts
sont minimes
il y a très peu de blessés et par
conséquent c'est plus le l'impact
médiatique l'impact psychologique que
l'impact en terme de de dégâts qui a
provoqué cette cette attaque salade va
arriver on peut pas exclure que ça
arrive encore en réalité puis comme je
vous le dis ça fait des mois qu'on
trouve des épaves dans la grande région
de Moscou plutôt vers le sud-ouest
puisque c'est de la qui arrive c'est
drone qui sont abîmés qui sont soit
brouillés par la défense électronique
soit descendue par la défense entière en
réalité il y a plusieurs raisons qui
font que jusqu'à présent on n'avait pas
vraiment vu survenir ce genre d'attaque
jusque sur Moscou même donc pour vous
Igor de la Noé il n'y a pas de doute sur
l'origine de ces attaques elles viennent
des Ukrainiens
a priori oui ça vient c'est d'ailleurs
probablement un raid de représailles
contre les raids que vous avez
présentées qui ont les Red russe qui ont
touché la capitale ukrainienne et les
autres villes d'Ukraine en réalité je
tiens votre attention sur le fait que
les Russes ont menées au mois de mai des
raids quasiment quotidiennement voir
plusieurs fois par jour comme ça a été
indiqué précédemment ce qu'on n'avait
pas vu depuis le début de la guerre
depuis le début de la guerre on était
plutôt sur un rythme de enfin à partir
du moment où c'est vrai donc commencer à
l'automne dernier plus précisément soit
tous les 15 jours tous les 10 jours tous
les trois semaines c'était beaucoup plus
étalé et là depuis le mois de mai on a
une intensification et donc on peut tout
à fait imaginer que ce sont les
Ukrainiens qui ont cherché à voilà mener
ce rêve de représailles ça ne pourrait
pas être les groupes russes dont on
parlait beaucoup notamment après les
attaques à Belgorod qui pourrait être
derrière ces attaques
c'est possible tout dépend du type de
drone qui a été utilisé la longe de
cédrones pour ce condensé ils avaient
une charge explosive qui était assez
limitée on parle peut-être de 20 kg tout
au plus
quel est leur rallonge on sait pas grand
chose on parle d'un nouveau type de
drone qui est jusqu'à présent aurait été
peu vu bon c'est encore un peu trop tôt
pour essayer de savoir concrètement de
quel géographiquement de quel endroit
ils sont partis mais je suis d'accord
avec vous on peut tout à fait pas
exclure que ils étaient lancés peut-être
depuis le territoire russe par des des
groupes sympathisants Ukrainiens ou des
groupes pro Ukrainiens mais basé en
Russie on peut rien exclure absolument
est-ce que ça peut s'inscrire selon vous
dans le cadre La Conte de la
contre-offensive contre-offensive
ukrainienne que l'on attend depuis
maintenant plusieurs mois
c'est possible alors là quand on écoute
les déclarations qui proviennent de Kiev
certains expliquent
comme Monsieur Boudanov donc patron du
renseignement militaire qu'en réalité la
déjà commencé monsieur zeliens ski
expliqué je croyais que ça y est les
ordres ont été donnés elle va commencer
dans les jours qui viennent on comprend
qu'il y a une guerre de l'information ou
une technique de désinformation pour
créer un brouillard autour de cette de
cette contre-offensive donc oui
rétrospectivement peut-être qu'on pourra
dire dans 8-10 jours que c'était déjà ça
faisait partie de la contre-offensive
mais une fois encore les dommages ont
été extrêmement marginaux par conséquent
c'est plutôt je dirais de la
contre-offensive médiatique pour niveler
l'impact médiatique des raids russes qui
frappent l'Ukraine depuis plusieurs
jours notamment les raids de ce week-end
qui ont été quand même extrêmement forts
et qui ont frappé notamment l'aéroport
de de Kiev ou se trouverait où c'était
trouver manifestement du matériel livré
par les Occidentaux et bien merci pour
votre analyse Igor Delanoë depuis Moscou
directeur adjoint de l'Observatoire
Franco